the Supreme Court has to make a big
decision this week on the subject of
abortion access there were
demonstrations over the weekend as a
high court weighs the FDA approval of
mifa Preston one of two commonly used
drugs in medical abortions a ruling in
Texas is spending that approval is on
hold along with restrictions on the
drugs used so for now it is still
available Nationwide Nancy Cordes is
following this story for us from the
White House Nancy good morning to you
good morning Gail well think of this as
this stay that was imposed by this room
court on Friday as a bid to buy a little
more time because it's going to expire
just before midnight on Wednesday in the
meantime the court is going to examine
this ruling restricting the use of
methopristone and decide whether to put
a longer term hold on the ruling all
this comes as new polling suggests that
most Americans think the abortion pill
should remain available
[Applause]
protesters hit the streets across the
country this weekend over the future of
the abortion drug mithipristone as the
Supreme Court weighs what to do about a
Texas ruling that could take the pill
off the market when you attack the
rights of women in America you are
attacking America Memphis Stone is one
of two medications used together to
carry out more than half of all
abortions in the U.S a new CBS News poll
found that 67 percent of adults in the
U.S think the drug should continue to be
available in states where abortion is
legal that includes nearly half of all
Republicans the Biden Administration has
asked the Supreme Court to reverse the
new restrictions arguing they would have
sweeping consequences for the
pharmaceutical industry women who need
access to the drug and the fda's ability
to implement its statutory Authority
South Carolina Republican senator
Lindsey Graham opposes abortion and once
proposed a nationwide 15-week abortion
ban but even he seemed concerned about
the Texas ruling I don't like a district
court judge issuing a national decree
even if I agree with the judge in the
meantime some democratic Governors are
insisting their residents will have
access to the abortion drug no matter
what we're going to make sure that
medication abortion is available in our
state
overall our polling shows that half of
all adult women in the US say that
access is to access to reproductive
Health Care is getting harder in a
statement the drug maker that produces
mifa pristine said it was gratified by
the Supreme Court's decision to put this
Texas ruling on hold even for a few days
and said the company will look forward
to the Court's ongoing consideration
Tony
all right Nancy thank you very much